(audience cheers)
- Oh my God, this-
- I feel like especially you ladies,
it's like y'all are like a girl group,
like with the tones happening right now.
- Thought we'd come here
to announce our girl group.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Exactly.
That's what we're doing today.
Have you met everyone?
- I haven't.
No, it's so nice to meet you.
I can't even believe I'm
sitting next to them.
- Do you watch Bridgerton?
- Are you kidding me?
Edwina? Penelope?
I'm like-
- [Kelly Clarkson] I know, I love it.
I love them.
- Me too, me too.
I have to ask though,
this is such a cool film,
Father of the Bride.
So this is the remake.
So had you seen the originals?
- Yes, yes, I watched-
- I only knew of the one original.
I didn't know there was
an Elizabeth Taylor one.
I only knew the Steve Martin one.
- [Adria Arjona] So
there's Elizabeth Taylor
and then the Martin Short, yeah.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I was behind the-
Yeah.
- [Adria Arjona] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I watched them,
but I think take on it is so different.
It's still very similar, the format,
and I think the story is so universal.
I mean, we all have family members
that are way too opinionated
and really get into our business.
- I love that your father
literally just said,
can you do that?
- [Adria Arjona] Can you do that? Yeah.
- Can you? Can you?
- Can you do that? Yeah.
= Do you feel like it was represented,
the Latin community?
Do you feel like it was represented right?
- 100%, and the beautiful thing,
and I think what I love
the most about this movie
is we're showing, you know,
there's a Mexican family,
there's a Cuban family,
and you'll see them sort of come together,
have their differences,
but at the end of the
day, we're all the same.
Maybe we eat different foods
and maybe we dance to different rhythms,
but at the end we're all human
and we're all going through
pretty much the same exact things.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, like ups and
downs, and love and loss,
all of that.
- So you'll see very much both sides.
The parents are getting a divorce,
so there's a conflict there,
and what I love-
- [Kelly Clarkson] That's fun.
- I know, especially when
you're trying to get married.
(Kelly Clarkson laughs)
- They're both probably
like, are you sure?
- [Adria Arjona] Sure about this?
So it's a really fun movie.
- The cast is amazing.
- Cast is amazing.
Andy Garcia and Gloria Estefan, what?
- [Kelly Clarkson] I
know. Estefan, I know.
I love her reaction in it.
She was like, oh!
- I still can't believe it.
I was so-
When we were prepping this movie,
Andy loves the FaceTime, so
he would just FaceTime me,
(Kelly Clarkson laughs)
and wherever I was, I
made sure to tell people.
- [Kelly Clarkson] That's amazing.
- I was like, excuse me, I gotta go.
Andy Garcia's FaceTiming me.
(group laughs)
Just one second.
Oh, sorry guys, it's Gloria Estefan.
One second.
(audience cheers lightly)
- [Kelly Clarkson] Gimme a minute.
- Just give me a minute.
- To pick up that name.
I love it.
- Pick up that name.
- Okay, so it's time for another break.
The newest version of Father of the Bride
premieres June 16th on HBO Max.